senator john kennedy louisiana has
thought a lot about what justice is
he joins us tonight senator thanks so
much for coming on i'm not a lawyer as i
know that you are
but my understanding was you assessed
the justice rendered in the case on the
terms of that case so if a guilty person
is convicted that's justice
why is this case a referendum on the
whole country
i'm listening to the congresswoman
and i'm thinking no disrespect but how
does
anyone get to be her age
and believe that drivel um
this to me is what this is all about
tucker
no fair-minded person believes that cops
many of whom are racial minorities get
up every day and go to work hoping for
the opportunity
to be able to hurt someone including but
not limited to people of color
color that's nonsense
but the walkeristas like the
congresswoman
they really believe that they really do
hate cops
just because they're cops they really do
want to defund the police
which will result in a a fantastic
impression of hell
the the walker ristas really do
believe that when uh when a cop shoots a
criminal
it is always every single time the cops
fault
but when a criminal shoots a cop
it is always every single time the guns
fall
these folks really do have contempt
for america they should have gratitude
but they have contempt
and they're not happy and will be happy
until they take a sledgehammer
to america's core now
you're saying to yourself probably look
this is america you're entitled to
believe what you want
and and i agree with that and i have
hope
for them um jellyfish have survived
650 million years without a brain so
there is hope for them
but but but what i'm disappointed in is
president biden
he has encouraged this i listened to him
last night
and he knows better no one
can get to be his age with his
experience and not know this is nonsense
and i hear people say all the time you
know cutting some slack
maybe he's lost his fastball no
he knows better and he hasn't he's
encouraged it
and it is a hurting america and it is
hurting people and i knew that president
biden would be left of center
i never dreamed he'd be left of lenin
and and he needs to to to to to stand up
yes the adults in the party need to stop
this because it's going to
this is pure imperial this is
infantile uh and and people are being
hurt
scary as hell senator kay thank you for
that i appreciate it